congress is an absolute clown show you
know i called
this yesterday i called this yesterday
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so
but alexandria ocasio-cortez
came out and she made these big claims
she's been calling ted cruz and josh
hawley murderers
because she said they sent
insurrectionists to come murder me
at the capitol hill riot and she
she said you know i'm i'm a victim of
sexual assault this is the first time
we've heard of this
and when i heard all these people coming
for me
i you know this was very traumatic and
cruz needs to resign now
and you say no aspect
no connection here between these random
thoughts
follows logic or is is persuasive in any
way
but i said look i wish that alexandria
ocasio-cortez were the kind of person
that i could believe but she is such a
pathological liar
she has been caught lying not just about
massive political questions
but even about her own biography she she
lied she pretended to
have been raised in the bronx she wasn't
she was raised in a very fancy suburban
town
i know this because i grew up in the
town right next to her the poorer town
next to her at the same time
i said i just can't believe her maybe
she could say a true thing but there is
no reason to assume that anything she
says is true
so turns out i was right
she said aoc that she was nearly killed
during the capital riot people were
yelling for her banging on doors coming
down the halls
turns out the person who was yelling for
her and banging on the walls and on the
door
was a police officer who was there to
protect her
here is the harrowing moment i
immediately realized that i shouldn't
have gone into the bathroom i should
have jumped in the closet
and so i i opened the door
when all of a sudden i hear that whoever
was trying to get inside
got into my office um
and then i realized that it's too late
that it's too late for me to
get into the closet and so
i go back in and i i hide back in
um in the bathroom behind the door
and then i just start to hear these
yells of
where is she where is she
and
i just thought to myself they got inside
they got inside
they they hear that they're here now we
know we've seen on twitter
that they they've been around the
capitol and so now they've gotten inside
now how do we know that this person
was a rioter or was not a rioter why why
should aoc have known
that the person who was knocking on her
door was not a rioter
well that's because she wasn't in the
capital
aoc i should how did i not realize this
at the time
aoc was not even in the capital
when the rioters entered she was in an
office building down the street
and i should have known this you know
members of congress spend most of their
time in
in office buildings that are not at the
capitol they're down the street
they're like a you know five to seven or
eight minute walk away from the capitol
now i figured well joint session maybe
she was in the capital
but we'd heard maybe they were evacuated
maybe she wasn't even there at the time
who knows
she was not there when they entered she
was not there for any of it
completely made up and she has been
saying now
for weeks that she was on she first said
that almost half of congress was killed
even though no members of congress were
even injured unlike say the
congressional baseball game when the
bernie bro almost killed steve scalise
she said she feared for her life she was
she had her life flashed before her eyes
all these sorts of things
she has been insinuating if not outright
saying i i haven't followed every
statement she's made but she's certainly
been heavily insinuating and i guess
implying you know necessarily she's
implying that she was at the capitol
that that she would have been there and
she wasn't
i understand that vanity
and dishonesty are occupational hazards
of politics
this is especially true of members of
congress
however this chickie is a
stone cold liar she
lies like a sociopath i've never seen
anything like it
even you know joe biden is another one
like this joe biden tells lies like
they're nothing this is why he had to
drop out of the 1988
presidential race because it's it's not
even the
kinds of lies he told joe biden never
went on tv and was
crying and saying this senator tried to
murder me and he didn't do that kind of
thing
but it was it was unsettling not because
of the
quality of the lies but because of the
ease with which he told them
joe biden will lie about anything like
it's second nature to him and it's
second nature to aoc
too there is no reason to believe
anything she says you know most
i know a good number of politicians and
if some politicians want to bend the
truth or they want to put some spin on
which you know goes with the territory
the vast majority of them that i've
known have not wanted to
outright lie that's always a rule don't
lie don't lie because
maybe you get caught in the lie and that
aoc doesn't matter
she will lie about anything if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video